>> Dana: IMPEACHMENT OR NOT
IMPEACHMENT, ACCORDING TO
NANCY PELOSI.
SHE DID AN INTERVIEW IN WHICH
SHE SAID "I'M NOT FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS NEWS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU SOME NEWS
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE I HAVEN'T HAD
THIS TO ANY PRESS PERSON BEFORE
BUT SINCE YOU ASKED AND I'VE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS,
IMPEACHMENT IS SO DIVISIVE TO
THE CONTRARY THAT UNLESS THERE
IS SOMETHING SO COMPELLING AND
OVERWHELMING AND BIPARTISAN, I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD GO DOWN
THAT PATH BECAUSE IT DIVIDES THE
COUNTRY, AND HE'S JUST NOT WORTH
IT."
SETTING ASIDE THAT LAST DIG, NO
IMPEACHMENT?
>> Greg: SHE IS A SMART COOKIE
IF I CAN STILL SAY THAT.
SHE KNOWS IMPEACHMENT WILL DO
THREE THINGS.
IT WILL BRING UP THE BEST IN
TRUMP.
HE LIKES TO FIGHT.
IT WILL GENERATE SOME OF THE IN
ANGER HIM INTO A FOLK HERO.
HE MIGHT LIKE THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS, LOOK WHAT IT DID TO
BILL CLINTON.
AND IT HANDICAPS THE DEMS.
IT SPREADS IT TOO THIN.
THEY HAVE TWO YEARS TO FIGURE IT
OUT AND SHE IS SAYING YOU TRY TO
WIN AN ELECTION.
STOP CHASING THIS GUY.
>> Dana: YOU THINK SHE'S
TRYING TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT
WERE GOING TO FOCUS ON
GOVERNING?
SHE SAID IF IT WAS COMPELLING,
OVERWHELMING, AND BIPARTISAN, WE
WOULD DO IT.
>> Juan: I THINK WHAT SHE IS
SAYING IS IN FACT A LOT OF THE
REQUESTS FOR, FOR EXAMPLE,
MATERIAL INFORMATION FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, A LOT OF CONTINUING
INVESTIGATIONS UNDER GOING ON,
SHE IS SAYING LET'S PUT OUR
MONEY ON THAT AS PART OF THE
2020 EFFORT.
BECAUSE BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE IS THERE GOING TO
SAY HEY, THIS IS STILL A PROBLEM
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHY PUT OURSELVES IN THE WAY OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ARROWS IN
TERMS OF SAYING IMPEACHMENT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO UNDO
THE 2016 ELECTION.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK SHE'S
TRYING TO HELP THE DEMOCRATS?
>> Jesse: IT HELPS THE
DEMOCRATS AND IT HELPS THE
COUNTRY AND RARELY DO THOSE
THINGS COEXIST BECAUSE IT WILL
DIVIDE THE COUNTRY IF IT'S NOT
AN OVERWHELMING HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANOR.
IF THE DEMOCRATS OVEREAT AND
IMPEACH ON SOMETHING AS PARTISAN
AS TAXES OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
OR STORMY DANIELS, YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE HUGE BACKLASH.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO HAVE A GAVEL
FOR THAT LONG.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT SHE IS OLD.
SHE IS SEASONED.
SHE HAS SEEN THIS BEFORE.
SHE'S VERY WISE.
YOU CAN HAVE THESE HOUSE THINGS
SLIP IN A HEARTBEAT ON WAR, ON
CORRUPTION, ON OVERREACH.
THE LAST TIME THE DEMOCRATS
OVERREACHED ON OBAMACARE, THEY
LOST THE HOUSE.
>> Dagen: THIS IS WHY THE
DEMOCRATS TOOK THE HOUSE BACK.
SHE SENT THIS MESSAGE OUT TO
THEM LONG BEFORE PEOPLE WENT TO
THE POLLS IN NOVEMBER.
IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
MESSAGING, SHE SAID CUT IT WITH
THE IMPEACHMENT TALK.
THEN SHE CAN LET JERRY NADLER